good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Friday if you
are watching us live on YouTube which
you always should be
www.youtube.com/watch you might wonder
it be wondering what's going on in New
York today it is a mess out here today
it is like raining it's monsoon e it's
foggy you can't even see out the window
craziness it's end of the world weather
and it's also like weekend weather like
there's no better day to sleep in than
on a day like this when your room is
still pitch black
here here sister not Friday weather so I
just think you guys should tell your
bosses like hey oh the morning to have
said it's weekend weather I'm gonna I'm
gonna hit it we tried but it's time to
go it's not working out brain is
obviously like the most annoying and
convenient thing ever but I don't think
unless you live in New York like it
changes New York for you like I walked
Theo this morning and when I was when
New York gets wet it's like soggy trash
and everyone is annoying and everything
smells and I bent down to pick up Theo's
[ __ ] and I was nervous about what was
gonna be on the ground that wasn't his
[ __ ] like he literally took a dump near
a tree that was like also a crack den
and there was like needles and trash and
poop and like the poop wasn't even the
worst thing like this is the life my son
has to leave because he can't find a
normal place that take a dump because
the city is a trash bin and any place
it's like cute to take a dump they have
signs you know like dogs are the problem
no human the humans need a little potted
tree what are we gonna do in there
totally I can't well yesterday was a
major day for me because I launched my
book club podcast boom the redheads book
club it's spelled Rea D because we read
but I have read it's a really good name
it's a really cute meme like when you
when you see it so I think everyone was
really excited I got so much positive
feedback I'm so happy that everyone is
so excited there's a Facebook group
started if you want to join it you want
to be a member of the book club after
you obviously subscribe in the iTunes
Store the pencil group is called the
redheads then the Instagram page is
called at the redheads book club and
then we are on iTunes and Spotify and
anywhere you subscribe to podcasts the
first official episode will drop on
Monday is it on Spotify yeah it is huh
oh we just move fast here at TN and
well you know what earlier this week we
were talking about Selena Gomez like
having to launch her rare beauty because
it was leaked and we kind of went
through something similar ourselves we
did most it wasn't leaked but the
toasters were figuring it out because it
was uploaded to iTunes it's made to do a
crash launch yesterday you a crash
launch but that's what we do best so I
was and I was also like so excited to
announce it that I couldn't wait another
second so I was so happy that you made I
live to announce stuff I know I just
wish I had more like jobs and projects
because then I could announce I will be
posting something sponsored on cloud
with her job later make sure to show it
some love I'm excited about that project
so we announced the first book for the
book club which is the husband's secret
the first episode which we recorded last
night that turned out to be so good
there's four of us on the show because
it's supposed to be like a club but four
people is kind of a podcast and I was
nervous that we were gonna talk over
each other the whole time and everyone
was so well behaved I went to dinner it
really moved very smoothly I'm not done
talking about the book cuz it's my
passion project I'm not done talking
about it either I went to dinner with
Margaux she literally sat down she was
like the redheads book club is gonna be
your number one podcast it was amazing
she had just come to dinner from
recording it and she was like Claudia
it's gonna be your best show and I'm
like okay this snatchler it was really
shocking it's such a value add to the
show because her perspective like the
difference between what Tina felt about
the book Rome is literally a professor
of literary studies and Margo who had no
time for this it was just really funny
really good the episode drops Monday
obviously four days for a lot of people
like is not enough time to read a book
so just listen to the first episode
whenever you finish the book like
there's no rush that's always there for
you it's always there for you and the
podcast is gonna be monthly so in
Monday's episode you'll hear what the
next book is and then we can all get on
the same rhythm schedule but I just
wanted to announce everything and drop
the episode as soon as possible cuz I'm
so excited about this everyone seems
really excited you know I don't know how
to read but I do think maybe I'll start
no but I'm really happy for everyone
like this seems like such an exciting
WIPP moment for women and a few select
men it felt like an exciting moment for
women and just like the start of
something really potentially beautiful
so make sure to subscribe in the iTunes
Store you know give us a five star
rating if you have faith in what we're
about to do I'm really excited about it
the start of something new I feel like
I'm on Broadway
and yeah so that was my you TNN show yep
launching and it's gonna have a big
month I think we have maybe three shows
launching very exciting in-house shows
we got some new talent coming so it's
very important that everyone follows at
toast news network on Instagram because
they were actually the ones who broke
the redhead book club story they were
like they were the ones who leaked it
first on the scenes so if you're looking
for all the inside scoop as to what goes
on here at toast HQ you should probably
check out toast news network on
Instagram I secured the handle that's
right
definitely well it's just gonna be it's
gonna be a great month full of premium
content is with another episode today by
the way last night I started because I
couldn't start this book until I
finished recapping the husband's secret
I think you can't cross over I started
to ask a Simpsons [ __ ] oh did you it's
just been like sitting at the edge of my
bed like looking at me like I'm only 15%
in and I was moved to tears already
really it's like she's such a the
writing is incredible she has a
co-writer on it but I just also believe
Jessica Simpson is like Albert Einstein
reincarnated right um and it's so well
done the story moves really well and
like her childhood we're still in
childhood right now is really
interesting and usually I don't like
reading about people's I don't know
anything about her childhood um it's
just really intense they survive I was
getting and she's being so brave and so
open in the beginning she's like it's
set in 2019 where she starts writing the
book she talks about how a few years ago
she got an option to write a book for
really good money that was basically it
had to be a boss how to live her life
like me because like she was the first
celebrity brand to hit a billion dollars
and she was talking at Forbes summits in
blah blah blah and she turned down the
book because like she felt like a fraud
oh my god I live for someone who like
turns down money that's where I aim to
be in my life where it's like I don't
have to like take every offer like I do
that now because I'm like thirsty but
like I just want to be the type of
person it's like a book maybe not right
now TV show maybe next year you know
yeah that is so like iconic just got to
keep churning it out and Jessica Simpson
continues she just like be my idol you
know yeah I'll let you know what's going
on with your birthday buddy also people
were saying it should be a book for the
book club it's not it's not the book
like that's a book I would wreak up on
the toast because it's pop culture
related but like the book club is more
for like book e-books also I don't
really think you could dedicate like
60 minute podcasts like a celebrity no
matter how good it is like a celebrity
memoir actually I'm only 50% in I feel
like I could but my friends like don't
we're not we're not gonna talk about
celebrity something book club like it's
about books that make you think put you
into different situations not I don't
think we'd ever do an autobiography
I hear you assists I do how was your
evening
that looks very premium it was lovely I
went to dinner at Indochine which
Margaux has been dying to go to ever
since she saw the cat retirees because
like they go there in every episode and
Margaux was like we please go to Indo
she and I'm like if there's a
reservation you could take it but you're
not gonna like the food because it's um
I think it's Vietnamese I don't know I
don't like I'm not sure what type of
cuisine it is but I literally ordered
the grilled salmon and I choked at the
table because it was so [ __ ] spicy
like I literally had to have the way
just bring me extra water I was dying
love to vibe didn't live for the food
they had good rice though but he was
very toasty they have like the same
wallpaper at the restaurant as we do in
our office so he definitely felt at home
and it was good for like Instagram
photos but everyone there was like so
you know nose in the air like down
looking down and everyone that I don't
want to be thirsty taking pictures I was
embarrassed but it was good and then I
went to Paris's birthday party which was
star-studded I had such a great time I
met so many great people and I found out
this morning that literally the second I
left Diplo showed up so just truly kill
me like I have the worst timing
when you look up man plans God laughs in
the dictionary you see a picture of you
leaving the party while Diplo's entering
no I literally have the worst gauge for
like is this party over or just getting
started I think that like I left at 1:00
and it was starting to thin out I think
like the corporate crowd like went home
you know and I didn't realize it would
be a second wave but of course there's a
second wave it's Paris Hilton like I'm
so mad at myself
I can't even tell Snitch that that Diplo
was there cuz we left and got a piece of
pizza which I had no regrets about in a
moment
actually had a [ __ ] amazing pizza
pizza piece of pizza pizza pizza pizza
piece of pizza at Pizza 33 which was
stellar and I got an A met the cutest I
don't even know if she was a toaster but
she said hi and like looked at me like
she was a toaster but now I'm realizing
I just assumed like why else would she
say hi to me you know and she was
wearing like a number like in a nametag
and with a number on it I'm like what is
on your thing she's like oh man I just
the speed-dating thing at this bar and I
was like Margot why the [ __ ] didn't you
go and she said this bar in her area
like this is the first one they did
she's like I met such a cute guy I was
like oh my God look at you know I was
like so proud of her I don't even know
this girl Mike you go says no it takes
like a big person to speed-date like at
a young age you know yeah and alone yeah
I think speed-dating is an amazing idea
I don't know if it was speed-dating was
like a singles event I apologize like
any singles event yeah yeah she was so
cute and she had like such a she was
like stop to mystic about the potential
I was really excited for her I mean
being single is all about your state of
mind you know
so Terry towards being single so like
true can be such a fun positive time in
your life or it could be deeply
upsetting and that's that's on us yeah
it's all about how you approach it okay
well I think it's time do you I don't
know like I never know when like the
dilly-dallying has dallied enough I feel
like we've dallied also it's Friday and
I'm just like so excited
I gotta get town oh you know what I'm
doing today I got my weekend I'm getting
lip fillers and Botox I was gonna I was
going to do it before I filmed my
special but then I realized I wanted
some eyebrow movement you know so much
of my comedy is physical and I want to
be able to like move my eyebrows like
I'm confused I'm happy and so now that
I'm done doing that I am going to get
lip filler Botox and I was looking at my
time up today and today so weird last
year was the first time I ever got lip
filler because I had that picture you
took of me in doctor Easy's office Wow I
know you could still see it on you and
Margo like a little bit well cuz you
know what I also threw my time up saw my
before-and-after and I don't even think
that I look like my before anymore I
don't think that you do either I kind of
want to go crazy like why not I don't
have any big projects coming up like if
I hate it like whatever it's temporary
that's what I love about filler you know
that I think that you should should i I
think that you and snit should get some
big Instagram lips so I went to the new
dermatologist recently for something
unrelated and she was asking me about
like my botox the stuff I'm like yeah I
do it like sometimes she was like where
do you do it I'm I could do it my
plastic surgeon and she was like come
come to me next time you know it's
always better to have a cosmetic
dermatologist do it I'm like oh I didn't
know that
so I'm going to her today dr. Karen
creme had some very excited um and I
think that I'm she's very conservative
she's like a like a
elevated Upper East Side woman so I
don't think she'll let me walk out with
duck lips
unfortunately because I would totally be
here for her but like she wouldn't I
don't think she loved me
you think it's always exciting to get a
new five yes and the fact that it's
temporary new fact like how fun should I
do it like yeah I think that you should
okay I know I can't convince snitch but
also like you're an Instagram person you
need Instagram lamps no and my face is
really becoming more and more full as
the day passes so I just think fuller
lips to match is absolutely necessary I
totally agree go for it okay I'm gonna
do it take the plunge yeah I'm gonna do
it I'm so excited I was actually just
looking at someone else's lip filler oh
this girl on tic-tac was like lip filler
check and it was like and then she
showed it and they looked so good I
should have taken a screenshot of it cuz
that's what I want yeah I need to like
get lip someone with lip filler I need
to get a picture up like what I like
yeah I'll figure it out there's some
good lip filler on The Bachelor but
there's also some so bad yeah
I won't shame anyone's lip filler but I
have it at the tip of my tongue do you
just want to say uh yeah it is time I
believe for the South Side Story is that
you yes you you you need to know before
you wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast yeah I mean you're not
you're not wrong but you're not right
about that you know and again I hate to
you know this is your show you built it
like I hate to come on your show and
embarrass you and say like no Jackie
you're wrong it's not time but that you
know the audience they deserve to know
and you by the way you want to hide it
from them you want to hide it from the
cues and I'm here to say I'm gonna let
everyone know I'm gonna blow up your
spot let him know since today's episode
you guys Jackie doesn't want you to know
but I'm telling you is brought to you by
vistaprint as a podcast host I'm always
handing out my business cards to people
that we want to interview or work with
and having a totally customized
professional-looking card is an easy way
to make a great first impression when we
hand out our business cards for mr.
Brent we know we're doing more than
passing along our contact info we're
making a connection we're impressing
potential guests or business partners
with the right business card you make a
statement about yourself that gives you
your connection a reason to choose you
and your business over the competition I
mean yesterday with Tyler see I totally
forgot to give my business card and I
feel like he's never gonna come on the
show again and that's why yeah he is
know like that thing to remember me by
he doesn't have a card with your
business information and that's my cross
to bear and I feel really guilty about
that
you an expert opportunity is coming
right now and we're here to help you own
the now with free shipping on any
business card in any quantity choose
whatever style finished shape or paper
you like and get free shipping and
because you can pick the colors fonts
designs and images it means you can
create something as unique and
compelling as your business if you're
ready to get started on your business
card it's so easy plug your information
and logo into hundreds of fresh designs
tailored to your type of money or money
company oh my god I've got money on the
brain and upload your or upload your own
design and original layout pick the
paper stock style quantity that's right
for you you can even upgrade to a unique
touch like rounded corners order and
receive your cards with free economy
shipping as if you needed any more
reasons to choose Vistaprint you can
feel good knowing that this different
uses only carefully sourced paper stocks
and selected inks your satisfaction is
100% guaranteed or your money back
they'll make it right so if you want to
be able to own the now hang tight we
will get we have an offer for you free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity just go to vistaprint.com
and enter the promo code toast for free
shipping on all business cards any style
any quantity but it's a limited time
offer so make sure you're owning the now
at vistaprint.com promo code toast sign
on own the now before we get into it we
need to talk about Tyler see yesterday
you know that's so fabulous I didn't
really think like before he came that I
was like gonna be so taken with him in
like a physical way but then I was like
I was just not that I didn't think he
was hot before like to me he was just
like a hot guy like there's a million of
them you know but he was like really
special like he's something special
yeah and he's nice and when he was
talking bout those kids at the ABC Food
Tours and the kid to put food in his
pockets like I was literally gonna I was
gonna start crying on the show like I
just I he's such an interesting
character to me because first of all
I've never seen someone gets so famous
from The Bachelor and be seem to be so
unfazed by it all like he's just a
regular guy yeah even afterwards we were
like chatting about work stuff and it's
like none of this faces him and it's
like cool yeah he has a really good
attitude about everything and like a
good head on a show he's gonna go far
mhm
I'm excited for him and it was really
nice to catch up with him and also just
like love to the viewership you know
everyone was excited everyone yeah it
was a great day for the toast yeah
numbers was okay first story like very
upsetting a judge has ruled that Kesha
defamed dr. Luke with text message to
Lady Gaga clean
he raped Katy Perry this singer has also
been ordered to pay three hundred and
seventy three thousand dollars and
change in interest on a royalty payment
from 2017 this is such [ __ ] like now
attached now gossip is considered to
famine Tory do you know like how many
decades this [ __ ] case is setting us
back yeah like since when is gossip
considered slanderous no and like she
wrote that text message privately
privately and even if it's a lie it's
not slender it's she didn't put it on
Instagram she sent it in a private text
message right and it's like the courts
who made it public right so it's like
you should act your slender dr. Luke
yeah
justice system it's just this is so
frustrating the latest development in
the legal battle between Kesha and dr.
Luke marks a win for the music producer
who sued Keshan 2014 for defamation
after she accused him of drugging and
raping her dr. Liu claims that Kesha
made up the accusation in order to get
out of her recording contract a judge
ruled on Thursday that this tik-tok
singer defamed dr. Luke when she claimed
in a text message to Lady gaga that the
producer had also raped Katy Perry
according to the ruling I mean literally
the justice system yet again just
failing humanity time and time like I I
just really feel like Kesha is starting
to like climb her bite out of this [ __ ]
hold that like she's been in for the
last 10 years and this is just like
really bringing her down and to be
honest I don't really know if Kesha has
that $375,000 because I remember that
Taylor Swift actually donated a quarter
of a million dollars to her legal fund
because it was so nuts and for so long
like she was paying so many legal fees
so I actually think this is devastating
in more ways than one I think it's very
devastating this payment like
financially yeah it's obviously
emotionally devastating that like dr.
Luke has quote-unquote one hmm
and now she's gonna have to pay up money
like that's a lot of [ __ ] money I
feel bad that I said something mean
about her makeup line earlier this week
everyone should go buy it we need to
support Kesha like we need to street
their music by her albums go buy it one
lipstick I'm gonna buy lipstick because
you're supporting women if you do it I
agree and like we can't start a GoFundMe
like first celebrity so I just think we
should support her business I don't know
where they sell her makeup but it's
called Kesha Rose and like just google
it okay we should all buy Lobster
also she is really taking steps moving
forward putting out new music like
trying to get past this and like
something like a financial blow like
this could really set her back and make
her indebted to dr. Luke and like I
don't know if she would have to even
maybe work with him again
writing it off so we need to we need to
help her yeah but like we can't have
like start a GoFundMe because like no
one feels bad for celebrity it's just
violet sick just buy lipstick yeah
actually recently learned in a few
meetings that a lot of celebrities are
in debt and a lot of because like they
all got famous like so fast like and
they they didn't come from you know
money they came from like humble
beginnings and they never knew what like
a 1099 is and so many of them forgot to
pay taxes like I didn't even know that
you could do this but a lot of
celebrities are on payment plans to the
IRS for like the next ten years because
they owe so much money but they don't
have ten million dollars right now so
they're paying like you know a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year that's
crazy I mean I guess that's kind of
flexible of the IRS like they're not
just jailing everyone right I just think
that like when you become successful
like it's so important that you like you
find like an accountant or business
manager and so many people don't and
also I feel like the definition of
success like to me you know you would
think oh when I become successful when I
become Jessica Simpson like I'll find an
accountant like no like when you start
being a self-employed person and you
start earning any money you need to
either learn how to do your taxes or
keep in good health
yeah it's I actually you know had a
situation you know because I like
graduated from college and like started
making money as a freelancer who the
[ __ ] knows what that is and there she
had to back pay taxes recently because I
didn't know how the [ __ ] to pay taxes
like when I was 17 yeah so that was
traumatic for me but thank God I paid it
but it was not fun no it's not taxes are
not fun and I pay that money and it was
like so devastating but it could but
that money was never mind like I always
old it to the government the government
is just like always looking at me I bet
they're watching right now being like
you know getting their little calculator
out figuring out crunching the numbers
that mean we're it's like yes I know I
know where it's like okay not only are
we we know we're not gonna tell you how
much you owe to the government in taxes
even though we know the exact number and
if you do your guesswork and you get
that number wrong you're gonna help yeah
it's so true I don't really understand
like hypothetically why we don't just
get a bill I don't know you're doing the
work anyway right like they are
crunching the
burrs on their calculators yeah so just
send me a copy the receipt I would like
an invoice from the government once a
once a year well I mean you mind up
getting one anyway you didn't get it
wrong right but you know if you have a
traditional corporate job like it's much
easier beautify our Texas and you get a
tax return
I've never gotten a [ __ ] tax return
and I like I'm so jealous of all those
means it's like when the tax turn it's
don't know that feeling I've never
gotten one I used to get those and now
there's there very few things actually
like miss and like create from like a
structured corporate life and like
health benefits taxes being taken care
of for you like anytime I do a job right
a bagel Friday any time I do a job I get
paid in full which is like exciting and
I think that I can spend all the money
but I can't actually put it all the way
and save it for Texas right it's so
frustrating so frustrating but like
grateful for the work next stories
little body positivity because Lily
Reinhardt says it's quote her obligation
to be strong and show confidence in
herself after troll claims that
Riverdale shows unrealistic bodies okay
so someone on Twitter obviously we're
all negative things began so true um
called out the Riverdale cast members
for quote being twenty five plus year
old portraying teenagers with perfectly
chiseled bodies they didn't question
whether the show aimed at teenagers are
contributing to unrealistic body
expectations and body image issues to
which the actress had the perfect
response I mean they're not the person
tweeting is not wrong you know yeah but
it's like that's that's TV so why take
it out on Lily run that CV and also it's
like you don't know what these people
are clearly you don't know what they're
going through because Lily Reinhardt
says actually not everyone on the show
is perfectly chiseled and even I feel
intimidated by the physique of my
surrounding cast mates sometimes when I
have to do bra and underwear scenes she
admitted that she felt very insecure at
times based on the expectation that
people have for women on TV what they
should look like before noting she's
worked on her own perception and
acceptance of her body image quote I've
come to terms with my body and that I'm
not the kind of person you would see
walking on a runway during Fashion Week
I have bigger boobs I have cellulite on
my thighs and butt and my stomach sticks
out rather than curves in this is still
something I struggle with on a daily
basis and it doesn't help when I'm being
compared to other women it's just so
crazy that and this is how like I
totally understand not that I've ever
had them like how
people have eating disorders because
everyone's mind and like how they see
themselves so different because to me
like Lili Reinhard is the perfect woman
you know and she feels insecure
comparing herself to other women like
there's always gonna be someone you
could compare yourself to because even
Lili Reinhardt gets insecure you know
yeah when she literally has the perfect
body
I hate Racine hustlers Oso River nil is
like an exceptionally good looking cast
very a chiseled but I feel like when it
does come to like the the lead women
like Camila and Lily Reinhardt are more
realistic healthy-looking
young women they are definitely compared
to other shows a little bit slightly
more realistic I think they're I mean
average age is that unrealistic
expectations like yeah they're 25 years
old playing high schools well that's Jen
no high school students should expect to
look like that remember the end of a fix
game remember at the end of Pretty
Little Liars when like literally the
girls for like 45 years old and like
still playing with who's a yeah but I
like Lily Reinhard she's always you know
getting on her soapbox on Twitter and I
actually really appreciate it I was just
grabbing my phone checking our stream to
see if you could see th EO sleeping in
front of us and you actually can in
literally looks so cute and like this is
just gonna be the best show ever because
he's dead asleep right between us like
he couldn't pick a side she lay with my
mom or my aunt both he wants both also
this is good practice for his patreon
channel yeah we keep talking about that
and teasing it but I actually keep
getting a lot of dams like where do I
sign up for that yeah I haven't seen
anything let's just launch it we
actually just bought a new camera so we
could start setting up our Theo cam okay
so Theo is gonna become a cam girl where
he's gonna make a patreon channel
filming himself just like being CEO it's
gonna be $4 a month right and you'll get
a 30 minute video once a month of Theo
either sleeping playing around and it's
create like we'll leave him in a
secluded area and like just leave the
camera and like see what happens
sounds really good yeah I'm subscribing
you what else sounds really good huh a
fresh home-cooked meal
you know before hellofresh I didn't
think that was an option but now I can
get mouth-watering seasonal recipes and
pre measured ingredients delivered right
to your door with hello fresh America's
number one meal kit hello fresh makes
cooking at home fun easy and affordable
their recipes are so delicious you can
break out of your dinner rut with
hellofresh is twenty two more than
twenty two seasonal chef curated recipes
each week they cut out stressful meal
planning and prepping so you can enjoy
cooking and get dinner on the table in
thirty minutes or even 20 minutes with
their quick recipe options the average
trip to the grocery store takes 41
minutes now if you live in New York with
all the treachery trash and traffic
definitely more there pre-portioned
ingredients that mean there's less prep
for you and less food waste so they can
help you eat more sustainably it's
flexible and fits your lifestyle you can
add extra meals or lunches to your
weekly dinner order or throwing yum
besides and desserts like garlic bread
and cookie dough easily change your
delivery days or food preferences or
skip a week whenever you need to we
really enjoy hellofresh you know making
it cooking it may be I'll make one for
Valentine's Day get a little you know
sexy in the kitchen I love hella fresh
it's just the best thing to get you on
track eating right and like cooking and
helping you learn how to I'm like using
the dishes you out in your registry of
that like you haven't used since you got
married
go to hell with fresh com / toast 10 and
use our code toast 10 for 10 free meals
including free shipping in order to be
qualified for this offer you have to go
to hellofresh
dot-com slash toasts 1-0 and use the
code toast 1 0 so that's toast 10 10 in
numbers TOA st 1 oh hello fresh com /
toast 10 and the promo code is toast Ted
check it out thank us later sign on get
to eatin yep
ok next story is really crazy oh sorry
before you jumped in there was something
I wanted to talk about that's not a
story but I really wanted to address how
I've been watching all the Jersey Shore
kids there in LA doing press for this
upcoming season that's already been
filmed and their Instagram stories
there's like so funny I've been watching
joey camasta a lot like they're all
together traveling in this like
stretcher a no-knock stretcher what do
they call it no Sprinter sorry and
they're so funny like situation farted
like it's just they're really hilarious
and I had totally forgot that Snooki's
quitting the show obviously this is her
last season because it's already filmed
and it's kind of making me sad yeah it
is sad but I I completely understand and
it's time and you just saw I haven't
been watching these stories I just like
even when it comes up in the toasters
group you know drama all flying drama
about the Jersey Shore people I'm just
like it's over yeah I know I don't watch
but I really enjoy them hanging out and
I feel like when they just like shoot
the [ __ ] sitting in a Sprinter van like
that's what the original show was if you
ever have time one of my favorite shows
to re-watch is Desperate Housewives
obviously but a close second is Jersey
Shore it's actually
phenomenal and really they set the
standard for reality TV yeah change the
game yeah now they're trying to
recapture the magic which is whatever
but I think it's like one of the shows
that will go down as like one of the
greatest of our time
you can't recapture the magic when
everyone is married with kids right and
like they're really only doing this for
the money not cuz they genuinely miss
living in a house together they're rich
they all have their own houses yeah okay
next story super crazy Nicki Minaj and
meek Mill reignite their beef both
making outrageous allegations outrageous
Liberty tweeting at each other on each
tweet has so many insane allegations
like you don't know where to look Nicki
Minaj and meek Mill have taken their
years long beef to a whole new level or
we should probably say a new low because
they're both leveling disgusting
unproven allegations at each other
horrible it appears Nicki fired the
first shot going off on me after seeing
that he liked a meme that took a shot at
her husband Kenneth petty okay
technically it he started it that's a
misleading because he's been like
commenting all the memes making fun of
right her husband but she started the
tweet Twitter threat right so she then
posted on Instagram calling Mika clown
and alleging he's a woman beater she
wrote you do it for likes hashtag
Twitter fingers beat women scared of men
she said he said you quote you beat your
own sister and taped it spit on her head
and taped it kicked me in front of your
mother and sent her to the hospital
sucking Drake dick make you feel tough
again move on dead
TMZ notes there is no evidence to
support those allegations it didn't take
long for Meek Mill to respond who said
the only way you can try to kill my
career is to say I beat women talk about
your brother convicted of rape and you
knew and paid for his lawyer okay little
brother touch that little girl too you
know I know you know you want me to
crash with your boyfriend and I won't
your boyfriend or her husband uh boy
husband Yeah right Sheila quietly got
married yeah and he also has a very
controversial background I do believe he
was charged with some sort of sexual
assault Wow Meek Mill also said you sad
you willing to crash your man because
you losing now and everybody in industry
know you a bad person you've been knew
your brother
you knew your brother was raping that
little girl that's why I got away from
you can you believe that you guys
imagine if that's true surrounded by
rapists talking what right because also
her
yeah yeah no I don't think you said that
I had so wild my god like did she
respond to that um well he posted uh
today saying for clarification I don't
hit women and I won't let my interviews
be filled with question about her any
situation to do with her when I come out
to do press for my new album no Devils
tricks
so I actually before this whole fight
really liked Meek Mill and Nicki Minaj
together I thought that they were really
cute and I did like kind of hold out
hope that they were gonna be like this
wrap like couple um it's obvious that
that's not gonna happen anymore and
while I'm sad I'm really you know shook
because the allegations are both so
horrible and you really can't take a
side here because either you're siding
with an alleged woman beater or you're
siding with an alleged you know rape
allow you're sympathizing right right
like even though these days I've been
like hating Nicki Minaj so much I just
think she's like the definition of a
woman who doesn't support other women
like she was happy being like the most
popular rapper female rapper for what
ten years and cardi B comes with one
song I'm like Nicki Minaj couldn't
handle it and that's just the type of
woman who doesn't support other women
and a Rona singer would not be okay with
that no she would not so I like I'm
obviously like like inclined to take
Meek Mill side just because like I hate
Nicki Minaj but like that I'm taking the
side of like an alleged woman beater so
I'm not that type of woman either
because like Ramona Singer I am a woman
who supports other women so once again
I'm standing firmly in the middle it's
I'm standing up on the sidelines not
participating like I said having an
orange slice yeah because either these
things are true and it's disgusting or
there's these things are not true and
they're defaming each other and it's
disgusting so there's it's a lose-lose
so yeah this is not defamatory but Kesha
is sending a text message is I can't
this is so crazy and reminds me of
marriage story because these are two
people who literally [ __ ] hate each
other so much and they're saying the
most disgusting things about each other
but at one point in time they were in
love it's crazy
it's neck where did you ever end up
seeing marriage story no but there's a
it's a thin line between love and hate
and that really was like the whole point
of marriage story is like you think like
even if you get a divorce with someone
like you think like you know them and
they're a good person they would never
do such and such to you but like when
you get divorced you literally become a
different person and it was like this is
this actually reminded me of that
because I don't think I could ever say
something
so mean and so bio publicly about
someone let alone someone I used to love
no but like you could only hate them so
much because you loved them yeah I get
that and then you can't get like you can
only and like hate is such a strong
feeling just like love you can only hate
someone that you've ever loved see I I
hear you but I'm just not thinking of
like all the people I really hate and
I've never loved them I just like
genuinely hate them because I'm a
hateful negative person and that's my
cross to bear
well then I mean I would argue that you
don't actually hate them like you just
don't like them but see I would argue
that that's incorrect
right because but maybe we're just
different me like I don't know that I
really hate anyone that I I'm just like
never knew very well you know like I
hate so many people from literally no
reason I actually went to dinner with a
bunch of my friends we were just like
gossiping and every person they brought
up I was like I hate them like I
actually I'm so negative and I really
need to stop um you know what I think
that you and I like like you know are
sometimes too negative but I think we do
try really hard to be as positive as
possible well you want to know what like
I'm negative trying to be funny and
trying to make people laugh so like
really at the end of the day I'm very
positive yeah no I I and also negativity
like you know it happened there's a
place for oh also speaking of there's a
place for it do you like my sweater
it's from the dirty jeans to our merch
shop that's right happening right now at
siya morning toast calm a lot of the
sweaters are flying off the shelves this
one in particular I'm wearing a size
extra large because I am extra large and
I just really enjoyed it I think you
should check it out so head over to shop
morning toast calm love it sinon shot
morning toast I was like that felt like
an ad next up why Kim Kardashian knows
Sun Psalm West is Robert Kardashian
senior reincarnated before you mention
that I'm assuming it's not the next
story
Chicago fell off her high chair and as a
scar on her cheek has had I hope she's
okay she had to get stitches oh my god
she's just a huge she's just like Peter
Webber she is so cute
okay sorry can you in an exclusive
interview with E News at the launch of
her skin's line at Nordstrom's the
mother for opened up about the things
that have happened since that have
convinced her the media members she
spoke to a medium who said that her next
son was gonna be her father
reincarnated and she's convinced that
the medium was right when that kid were
they talking about sale of
my son psalm is probably the happiest
baby alive she told he news he's always
smiling always happy she brought up a
moment from keeping up season 16 on our
show we showed that we were in Bali and
a woman a blind medium came up to me and
said that I was gonna have another son
and that it was gonna be my father
reincarnated she had no idea she went on
no one knew no one on my crew knew that
I had a surrogate that was pregnant with
the boy
Wow the makeup mogul went on to reveal
the moment setup happened off camera
that convinced her and her famous family
that little Psalm has the late patriarch
spirit okay quote my baby nurse I had to
go out of town they really needed her to
come in but she had a baby shower that
she had to go to and I said it's okay
you can bring my son to the baby shower
if that's okay with you I really needed
the help she brings him to a baby shower
and a woman comes up to her and said is
this your son and she said no no I'm
just watching him and she said well I
just have to tell you please tell their
mom this is a family member of hers
reincarnated what two people said that
yeah that numerous joy I just got chills
like on my cheeks mother it was a story
yeah I'm like what thank you I'm like
Kim's letting her kid go to some random
baby Shepherd vet numerous strangers
have told the 39 year old the same is
what made her start to think the
reincarnation could be real so spooky
multiple people that had no idea that
was my nanny or anything have caught my
baby to say that he's a family member
reincarnated okay my whole family all
the time thinks it's my dad and it's
just so emotional and close to home
that's how we feel about th geo because
he is the reincarnated spirit of our
Father
agreed she also said he's left-handed
like my dad so all these things happen I
don't even know if I believe in
reincarnation but I do now I want to
believe it do you believe in
reincarnation um I like the idea of
reincarnation but I've never met someone
aside from th EO who like made me think
that you know someone was reincarnated
yeah you know Phoebe Buffay was
reincarnated she was like a civil war
hero been she been reincarnated like
you're Henry the eighth's little brother
yeah I don't remember much but I I don't
know if I necessarily believe in
reincarnation like I don't think the
same person like lives multiple lives
but I think like a dead person's like
soul will be a part of a new person so
you know what I mean yeah like their
soul never goes away but like you don't
live multiple lives that's what I think
but then I also think in a situation
like this it can
just explained by genetics like right
some have left a lot of the DNA not even
the left handedness but just the
personality traits of Robert Kardashian
you know yeah because people like I feel
like that's genetic what is my mom is
25% Robert yeah Robert I actually was
watching um heed the other day and they
were playing all the episodes of
Kardashians and they played the season
where Kim had her Paris robbery and then
they threw her that birthday party and
they didn't want to do this they wanted
to surprise her but they didn't want to
come out and scream surprise because she
had literally just been through some
traumatic and Rob Kardashian was there
and blac chyna was there too and it was
so weird I'm like Rob brought the cake
and like he obviously never leaves his
house but Kim really needed him around
that time and I just thought it was
really sweet and it made me remember
like how much I really miss Rob
Kardashian and I just wanted to say on
the show like I really hope he's doing
well I feel like he's doing well and I
feel like we'll be seeing more of him
soon do you yeah I feel like he's on the
up like remember that picture of him and
stars like getting in the car oh my god
yes that's also what needs to happen
like went out with Connie and her
friends he needs to find true love with
someone who's in the Kardashians circle
already like blac chyna was a true
outlier and I think he learned his
lesson like by leaving you know his
gated community he just needs like a
Stas or like what a jordan woods was
like someone mm-hmm speaking of gated
community jessica simpson lives in
Hidden Hills I was reading she's talking
about her house I was like where did
Jessica Simpson live I kind of thought
she might just live you know in the
middle of the country somewhere random
right the celebrities love Jesus so
private you know when I could never
really see her out and about but I
googled it and she lives in Hidden Hills
which is also the gated community where
jeffree star lives my Kardashian's Dre
straight every week that's my goal I
know that's like a really high goal but
we have to live there I mean that means
you have to move to LA so I'm right
there with you know what I'm just gonna
look up really quickly like Homes for
Sale in Hidden Hills like what's the
cheapest one yeah homes for sale in
Hidden Hills I don't even think you
could like Google them you know what I
mean
really realtor.com perfect okay this is
a 1.5 million dollar house Wow
it says it's in Hidden Hills paseo pre
mario Calabasas California I mean for
1.5 million dollars this house is like
not that big but honestly it's super
cute it's you in the gates it gets I
think I don't know how do you know if
it's like beyond the
or we'll have to do some research oh my
god wait actually these houses are
sickening I cannot that one well there's
a house in Hidden Hills for not $929 Oh
nine hundred twenty-nine thousand and
it's contract pending of course lots
like that don't stick around forever
no okay all ready for our fifth and
final story I don't know is it brought
to you by love book then cuz if it's not
that I'm not ready oh then it's brought
to you by love book love books help
customers express the sentiments that
may be difficult to say out loud
each book is completely customizable but
most coast customers use them to list
the reasons why they love someone users
can create characters that look just
like themselves and the recipient down
to the outfits and accessories while
customers have the option to personalize
each page as much as they like the love
book express option creates a complete
book with just a few clicks love books
are the perfect gift for Valentine's Day
and we know that's coming up very soon
love's book even offers a membership
program now you'll save immediately on
your purchase today and also receive 50%
off any future purchases love book is
not for yourself it's always for as a
gift it is ideal for that special
someone that really deserves a
meaningful president present like Theo
what visit loves book online.com slash
toast to receive a special 20% discount
today only for our listeners that's love
book online comm slash toast to receive
a special 20% discount only for our
listeners you know so many people listen
to our show and they complement us they
say oh guys you're hilarious
but no it has literally ever told me
that they love my voice you know I was
just thinking because during that
podcast Rita I was trying to be like
love book online sign-on love your book
but I don't think I will ever like be
the type of person who like people just
like live like you know Nick vile his
voice was actually used for the comm app
like to bring people to sleep but I will
never be contracted for one of those
jobs I do think that our voices hold us
back from like real because I think a
lot of toasters talk just like us and
they don't hear anything wrong with our
voice but when new people listen to our
show they're like what how can you
listen to this vocal fry' for so long
but actually last night doing the
redheads book club Rebecca has the most
amazing podcast because she's so
soothing
um I think people are really gonna
respond to her I think that's gonna be
my goal is to try and speak with more
grace and elegance and also style
I think that this is see me even trying
to be like elegant and great still
sounds like [ __ ] it's just a summit to
be okay maybe I'll try for the next one
do right now there's just something so
FRA about us I don't by the way what
does a FRA mean we're like the Friars
Club I mean see that it went out of
business did it I heard that I got
raided by the FBI we just said because
it used to be a very fabulous place for
fabulous people celebrities rich stars
to hang out we used to do the Comedy
Central roasts there but now I guess
it's irrelevant welcome to the club the
Friars Club Netflix will now let you
disable its awfull auto-playing feature
do people consider though the autoplay
feature to be awful yes like you can't
just think about watching a show before
it starts playing for you and you're
sucked into watching it like I just want
to read the description oh wait wait oh
I'm sorry
which autoplay when okay when you're
looking for something and the trailer
starts playing yeah oh my god okay that
is the worst I thought you meant between
episodes I'm like oh so I have to click
it no no Netflix customers have
complained for years not the frustrating
annoying autoplay preview feature that
occurs on Toto play preview oh my god
it's so [ __ ] today the company
announced that subscribers can finally
disable oh disabled I can't like talk
soothing and read I but I do love to
disable oh okay people can choose to
disable autoplay in two different
formats one that automatically starts
the next episode in a series and one
that auto plays previews while browsing
obviously the second one is the problem
yes I like the ability to just sail into
another episode but the previews it's
like you're just trying to watch chill
the [ __ ] out and like everybody you have
to pee so you put the clicker down yeah
and all of a sudden like you're watching
season 1 episode 1 it's so annoying it's
really annoying that I'm glad that
Netflix is hearing and changing and
evolving and I think it's important it
is but like it shouldn't take so long
for customers to be heard I feel like
back in the day when everyone was really
gung-ho on snapchat there were so many
things we like wanted and they never
gave to us that like when Instagram
launched their stories they just did all
the things people were asking for and
that's why people switch so fast like if
you don't listen to your audience like
they will get annoyed with you
eventually so they shouldn't have taken
so long
to make the changes like to the like
navigation it's all we're asking them to
you know change their whole business
like just it's a little feature of like
a user-friendly navigation I think that
companies who listen to their audience
like are ten times more likely to
succeed I agree there's a small
Instagram thing that's happening on my
stories I'm just gonna put out there Q&A
no I don't really do Q&A but when you
share say I share a photo from the
morning toast to my story and I'm gonna
like write a little text about it
I write the text and then I go to move
the text down but the picture moves not
only text me oh my god text gets lost
behind the picture I have to then move
the text ugly job separate them so much
so that's it the screen doesn't get
confused I'm trying to move yeah and
then like my photo is no longer centered
perfectly and each then slide of my
story the photos all over the place
because it's not uniform Jackie you said
it you know another issue I'm having is
it happened to me yesterday is when
you're looking through your questions
that you got in a QA if you go down you
pick one you select it and okay guys the
fibers yes you start to answer and this
is this has happened to me for like the
last six months but I usually catch it
I'll tap a question like what's your
favorite soda I'll tap it I'll start
recording and then I realize the
question that comes up is not what's
your favorite soda it's two of the best
recommendation for a vibrator which is
what happened to me yesterday someone
asked if you could have your fingers
like serve beverages like they were
fountain soda like what would you want
the five beverages to me so I'm going on
there I'm like this is such a great
question I said die coke Diet Pepsi
fresca diet raspberry Snapple and diet
dr. pepper by the way I copied you and
got two hi dr. pepper in my house and
it's literally the best beverage
everything in the sort
it's everything of the sort but it
realized the question that actually
populated was do you have any
recommendations for a good vibrator so
I'm on there being like what a great
question and it was mortifying so that
really needs to be fixed ASAP Mark
Zuckerberg so funny also I think it's
just something with their home screen
like even when I'm on my notifications
tab and I'll go to someone's had me in a
faux
say someone mentioned me in a comment oh
I'll click the photo and instead I just
followed the person above who just
followed me and like requests on
requests or crap I'm always like looking
through my Instagram feed like finding
right random girls named Jaime that I
accidentally followed like I'm sure it's
like so exciting but like I unfollow
immediately yeah and I it needs to stop
doing that I need to get a notification
are you sure you want to follow this
person yes
yeah it's true like you should just have
to click twice to follow someone but I
do think that now that we've put this
out there like if enough people complain
yeah
if it just becomes part of the zeitgeist
that these are problems Instagram will
will fix it you know like they need to
make that that story's template more
sensitive I guess or less sensitive and
just know what I'm trying to do when I'm
trying to do it yeah what do you think I
agree I think my sister I think my aunt
Jackie should be posting on my Instagram
or he's in my video is that how you feel
a lot yes it is she's been slacking has
that money takes pictures of me in the
bed Theo is that nice she's right here I
don't care she's slacking but mom why do
you only take pictures of me in bed
because I like to be in bed Jackie I
choose to be there yes do tell her yes
Jackie I choose it mom is always dying
to take me out and I say no that's not
terrible yes if you're watching live
let's cut to my camera say hi DT oh do
you say ID to everyone Theo's been like
now that we have our own studio and I
really feel like I'm a true business
owner like i am i bring theo every day
that there's not a guest and it's so
exciting oh you should have been here
yesterday for Tyler Tyler would have
loved him yeah Jackie made me really
regret not bringing Co yesterday like
imagine a picture of Tyler and Theo like
[ __ ] his Instagram would have blown up
I'm like so mad about it
[ __ ] oh this is so cute let's recap size
of New Jersey
oh you watched I watched and then what
you do yeah I have to finish editing the
redheads I work out at the live method
I'm still Marique on doing my home and
it's just I'm almost there but I'm just
gonna make the rest of the state count
before I embark on the weekend okay so
real house was in New Jersey
oh we had Margaret's launch for no not
launch
celebratory party for 20 years in
business which
quite an accomplishment and the party
looked stellar it's so interesting
please stop licking the mic um it's so
interesting to watch housewife parties
where you know like the light it was so
bright in there which like normally I
don't think a party would be but it was
because they were filming and there was
no music
honestly the party looked really great
and really swanky all of the desserts
and treats looks so good it was making
me so hungry I've just been like really
hungry recently the housewives have been
giving lawrence scott's events like so
much work he does all of Ramona's
parties he did Melissa Gorga's fortieth
he did Margaret's caviar fish caviar
dreams tuna fish budget party which is
such a cute name such a cute name I just
I love the March she looked so fabulous
oh my god I'm when she got on the stage
and literally was like I literally I'm
here to thank one person my mom like I
started crying
it was like so meaningful I feel like
she speaks a lot about like the strife
in their relationship and I just wasn't
expecting her to like I thought she's
gonna say Joe Benigno is so meaningful
and so touching I'd be mom was so
touched by it yeah I feel like her and
Joe have like a really really good
marriage like yeah she got me she
couldn't forget two things right and
he's just so happy for her
hey Jackie you took the words right out
of my mouth she like hopped off stage
she was like oh I forgot about you and
he's like you did great he's just like
so supportive and I realized the other
day he's literally my father-in-law and
I can't watch the show anymore because I
literally see Bruce from jump inning
know and bed was actually like in the
room and I was watching him like Ben
look at this guy he's your dad Abed was
like wow he actually does that so honey
he actually is Oh Theresa got to go into
the ice facility god I forgot that
that's how the episode started I had
such a pit I had such a pit thank God
that she got to go um geez that's just
like so rough but I am really excited
for the reincarnation of Teresa Giudice
I do wonder if she got allowed in
because she's like a well-known person
or they would have let anyone like um I
I don't think you just get into the ice
facility because your reality TV star
but I do think like they can verify that
she's Teresa Giudice by just googling
her right you know that's so true I
think it probably helped
yeah um few other things I thought the
episode was kind of really boring I'm
excited for the Jersey Shore next week
so am i no bed for Billy I felt bad for
Billy Aidan because it was not fair for
Joe we're going to say that to him but
then what Jackie what Jennifer said
about
Jokke needing to suck dick was the
horrible thing by the way it was
horrible it's the exact same crying yeah
but she didn't say it to Jackie did she
I don't she said it behind her back I
just think all the guys like first of
all having the men take on the women's
drama never works out they should be
totally like neutral um and then all the
guys like ganging up on him and then
making like speaking about his wife in a
sexual way especially they're like
Turkish conservative like I felt really
bad for like walking away he's so mature
and above it and he's like okay listen I
tried to like do this reality TV thing
like right right right
where I draw the line but they got when
the next in the preview of the next
episode he like looks like he gets
wasted at the Jersey Shore so like it
looks like they're all fine yeah but I
felt bad for him in that moment yeah
especially because they felt they were
very isolated like from the party and
even though I do things like Jennifer
needs to be put in timeout
she's becoming more and more unbearable
bill didn't need to go down with her on
that one I know and I do wish like he
doesn't care and I like get involved in
the drama and listen but I'm sure if he
had to comment on it he would tell his
wife to chill the [ __ ] out and she would
listen to him well she does it's like he
said that she should apologize for her
apology was [ __ ] oh my god and
honestly like normally I don't like
Jackie and it's just like accept the
apology but it's a terrible apology it
was and how many times now it's like
three different part three parties in a
row but also like for that crime was i
calling her cheap and like criticizing
her parenting like she shouldn't have
apologized at a party she should have
taken her to line it required more
required more not just like listen I'm
sorry like it required listen yeah no
I'm sorry it's she did it didn't require
like listen I'm sorry let's move past it
like easy for you to say yeah it was it
was really hurtful what she did and I'm
really like I love her so much but I
also can't stand her and he spent so
much of last season apologizing for the
article yeah um that Jennifer needs to
do half as much yeah um yeah it was a
kind of boring episode let me think what
else happened Jackie went and cleaned
her dad's house oh I actually thought
that was very funny and I think her
dad's hilarious like I think he's
actually good on TV I think so too
with his sunglasses and his fedora he's
really cute his house is like straight
out of the seventies I think the sun's
coming out like this guy is like parting
it's biblical and a cloud so moving so
quickly th e Oh looks so cute yeah cut
to my camera like could you die I mean
literally we can't end the show now the
Sun is out literally
a model oh my god I'm gonna someone take
a screenshot of this and tweet it at me
thank you
did we just I can't like this literally
the whole room just lit up the Sun came
out what do we do this is so crazy I
just ran out of things to talk about no
I know I guess I could talk about the
book club some more please do make sure
to subscribe head over to the redheads
book club it's one Episode a month and I
do feel like even if you're not a huge
reader reading has become like such a
value add in my life and I just want to
pass on this gift it's funny on the book
club episode let me talk about how we
talk about reading like we just
discovered this new thing nobody think
adults like there's something a point in
your life where obviously like reading
was a chore as a child so you never
could appreciate it and it's one of the
things like you grow up to appreciate so
I do feel like everyone has like a
renaissance when it comes to reading a
renaissance Wow spelled re ad a
Renaissance let's have a front asan
swell I really haven't watched friends
since like January first and I'm
devastated and I was gonna buy it on
Amazon keep talking like a big guy are
you gonna buy it because on Amazon they
don't have it in a bundle so I'm just
too lazy to buy each individual season
by the season watch the first one they
might think about it I don't really need
the first season like I don't love the
first season so should I buy those start
the second I know none then it's just
like so many logistics I can't feel bad
for you I wish Amazon sold a digital
bundle I'm sure they will now that
they've heard this yeah because they
listen to their customers they do um
anyways once you hang up on us go to the
redheads book club on iTunes Spotify
subscribe leave five stars first episode
drops Monday before the toast so what
you will have it next time I see you and
I'm just so excited to start this
journey with you guys thank you all for
the support I felt like so supported
overwhelming like really everyone's
really excited about it made me even
more excited and all the redheads we're
all just excited so excited for this
journey and if you're looking for more
content there was a new episode of this
snatchler this week moon with Lauren
Elizabeth date night with Raven and Adam
plus five premium episodes and we've
released our first patreon of the month
so there is a never-ending stream of
content for you to listen to while you
wait for today to end so thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube please feel free
to subscribe give this video a thumbs up
comment we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found
that Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio I Heart Radio cashbox wherever you
can listen to podcasts find us the
morning toast subscribe leave a five
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are
I'm we love you guys so much have an
amazing weekend and theall says he loves
you bye